yeah see this is why I don't take the
black pill man I am so on the white pill
train because over the long course of
History Liberty has advanced if you look
at things on a long enough timeline sure
have we lost some short-term victories
sure but the Libertarians have slowly
made gotten the big wins Roe v Wade was
a big one that was you know that
happened last the first time I was on
the show last time and the anarchists
and the people who want to be left alone
we would see things a little bit
differently but but you do make a very
good point because especially when it
comes to states rights especially when
it comes to gun rights we have seen it
grow in in a way that the federal
government has been having a hard time
trying to of course stop you look at
people where you look at States where
people could conceal carry they're
they're becoming more and more abundant
by the day that's a huge major victory
and I I think when we look at you know
the decentralization decentralization of
power there's a lot of optimism there's
a lot of Hope but also at the same time
I think we're seeing the system panic
and kind of get angry and lash out